[Applause]
no but in all seriousness bro y'all
gotta put some respect on the whites bro
yeah but we gotta get back to why indian
people look so good why
we never go to the bottom of that dude
yo did we get to the bottom yet
i think we got to the bottom yo can you
please cut when i just went like that
i hope you didn't have that i don't know
i caught at least sassy no
for no reason like my body took over and
i went
yeah he's from atlanta over here he's
african american
that's what obama did when he hit that
three oh yo put some respect uh
you'd think that three has something to
do with it no no
low-key low-key you know you you miss
obama with you
i'm not gonna lie bro you miss him but
he hit that three it was just
that was some classic swag one shot
bang then lower the mass to talk his
[ __ ] i didn't like how he repeated it
twice
i didn't like how he hit the mask he was
like that's what i do
and then people didn't hear him so he
had to take it down he said twice i
wouldn't like if he just ripped that
[ __ ] off
threw that [ __ ] in the air like confetti
and said that's what i do
[ __ ] he said [ __ ] social distance and
pulled it down yeah yo
i think obama might have the energy of a
trump supporter
he's going swagged out as [ __ ] burying
the three and then says you know what
[ __ ] health yo pull that [ __ ] down
that's what i do
that's what i do that's what trump's
gonna say if he wins the election again
he could go that's what i
do what if he wins i win elections i'm a
winner
you're gonna lose did you see his
daughter wrapping the city girl's verse
no oh you didn't see this no going after
it oh she got a chill how could you go
oh
wait let's just keep going come on no
she's going after it bro she
yeah she getting smoked out guaranteed
bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
mark really trying to get murdered by
everybody anyway
so what is malia is how old before we
continue having this conversation
look up malia's age who's going to do
that too but
look up age what age is this i was going
to talk about sasha because she's in
college for sure
but i think they both are in college now
i think they're both of these okay okay
this is important research are we there
yet 22 and 19.
got it anyway she yeah somebody is
definitely
cracking that out bro come on what what
you don't think so
you don't think she can ever since the
debates i say
come on man all the times that's my [ __ ]
this is malarkey yeah what happened
over using man come on man come on man
come on i like that i like that [ __ ]
come on man
you know seriousness do you think she's
getting smoked oh it said i tried to get
you off
but let's get to the moment
what school is she at she's definitely
out of college and the secret service
i'm walking around with her everywhere
yeah it'd be a little creepy bro
if what she's just catching him misha
that would be a little creepy too what
if she was just
catching it yeah she was getting smoked
i was like
[Laughter]
yo do you think al there's got to be
something there
you know what i mean you don't think
she's praying five times a day
[Music]
[Laughter]
on them hands and knees bro friend five
dollars a day four head against the
floor katie sweet goodness gold let me
see that obama roll
[Laughter]
come on dude not been all seriousness
how you don't think that
no i don't i don't think at all so you
think she's a virgin dude
yeah do you think she's that sexually
friendly no i think they're still
virgins what about the older one do you
don't think she getting that smithereen
no you think she's just rapping wet uh
just not knowing
she wasn't rapping whop she was writing
with city girls that's even crazier than
that
dog yeah city girls is nuts bro yeah
talking about
nuts
what dude al can you just look at the
video of her doing it and then it might
change your mind bro you don't think
she's getting drone struck bro come on
oh my god
that's crazy that is crazy why is that
crazy i don't know
but that is kind of what we should call
when you bust on a girl
incoming
[Laughter]
oh incoming anyway so what do we think
is going to happen what's the
what's the fate of america guys
would all that alarmist we were doing
before i think nothing's going to happen
i don't think there'll be any writing i
don't think there'll be any fun okay i
don't i don't think there's gonna be
something
social media posts there's gonna be some
little [ __ ] that the media is gonna blow
up
yeah like there's gonna be like a one
square block in chicago where there's
like a trash can on fire they're gonna
be like look at the
panic in the streets i do think the
people that want to loot and are playing
a loot
are going to do it yeah they're going to
try yeah but i don't think it's going to
be something wild
yeah so like these people like people i
was saying before people are telling
like
stock up on water and fill up the car
with gas i'm like
i don't think it's going to be all that
and i know i'm more like fatalistic than
you guys i think i think it's gonna be a
little crazy
really yeah it's gonna be tense like
worst case scenario there's gonna be
like a court case
like trump's like worst case narrator
trump there was a court case for
gore and bush we didn't give a [ __ ] back
then about gore bush
right that went to court for weeks this
is different the stakes are different
for both sides
everybody feels like the country is
riding on this election
but who wins wait what if i had to guess
i would say biden but i don't feel
confident
about that really yeah i kind of feel
the same
i say buy them but i don't feel
comfortable uh confident about it i can
see trump losing the popular vote or is
really really close i think that's life
and then
i think that uh he could win electoral
college so i'd say i think trump might
squeak it out
i think trump wins bro and the popular
dude i think it's i think it might be
easy if you asked me two weeks ago i bet
i think biden got it man
the last two weeks i don't know i mean
that is what happened in 2016
so for me to act like that's not valid
is crazy because we've seen it
with trump i if he wins the credibility
of the polls is gonna be
done done done forever done they're
saying that he has a bigger lead than
what hillary had so the one thing that i
read i didn't have
it yeah the one thing that i read that
could be like oh okay maybe trump does
have this
is apparently 20 percent of voters last
time were undecided leading up to the
election
and then a bunch of those people swaying
trump i think and a lot of that was
[ __ ] i hate hillary they just say
that they're undecided but they're not
yeah yeah i think it that's what i was
trying to say about my
my nerd friend that was doing like the
calling all right half a bite
yeah i hate that i want to talk about
that what calling on behalf of people
i've gotten so many [ __ ] calls and
texts
non-stop about the [ __ ] elections i
have not because i don't really be
voting
i've gotten a lot i think i'm registered
i'm registered well your vote truly
matters
yeah so you're going to vote in every
election i'm registered independent and
so i think i just get hit up non-stop
i've gotten like 10. oh yeah
yeah and florida are you [ __ ] kidding
me the most annoying one i got a text
from someone that said like we got it
was from like the democrats they were
like oh we got to get trump out
and then they they put stars in trump
like they bleeped
trump's name that's stupid it was like
tr
like voldemort and yeah i didn't want to
say
i was like he whose name may not be
mentioned i was like what are we doing
like
what is it i'm not being named they
don't even know nothing about potter you
know
[ __ ] about problems harry potter fans
damn i got that [ __ ] wrong bro yeah
[ __ ] slytherin
oh my god you're a real slytherin bro
come on yo
yeah you i might be slytherin that's why
i don't know that [ __ ] ass saying
yeah cause that's for [ __ ] who are
scared to say his name but i'm just out
here like voldy
yo stop
in harry potter world i mean there's no
black people now there's one i counted
there's one he's in the movie for two
seconds yeah what's his name
something i don't know black
the other serious black not so serious
uh they named a guy sirius black
instead of having a black character yo
jk rowling is
racist bro she's a girl hates [ __ ]
she hates black people she made one good
movie
about a utopian society where only white
kids
went yo this girl is [ __ ] up
yeah no
not a single indian in that [ __ ] two who
yeah the patil twins patel i don't know
why she spelled it with an eye but
oh yeah books doesn't even know how to
spell that they're in the books are they
in the movie they're in the movie too
i ain't no movie bro i ain't seen them
in a movie i wouldn't
recognize them 14 fingers and [ __ ]
holding that wand mad big
how many wands they get the potential
gravel with their
brother who would be twins right four
sons
no for real though are they actually in
the movies yeah you probably just didn't
notice because they're
not white i mean i would notice them
more if they're not white
yeah flying the milk bro they there bro
they they go to uh [ __ ] ball
with
ron and harry i think you don't even
know who they go to the ball with bro
i know ron think harry you think there's
two of them you don't even know if the
lead of the movie
go see the [ __ ] ball with the
paddle twins where'd he go who we go
with
who harry the girls twins yeah
oh there's chicks
y'all suck y'all trying to say i'm not
slytherin
yeah or wait what were we all trying to
say we're shell-shocked you keep saying
the v-word he
whose name may not be said
hey listen she's killing me but i don't
even know what the patel's did or what
they are
or who they were getting smoked out yes
we do who
they got that mish yeah they were they
were getting that straight midge
they got smashed who was smishing ron
wasn't dating her
not ron was dating hermione
that's stupid y'all don't even know
no indians bro there are
indians in the movie i know one of the
teachers was indian yes
who the big [ __ ] yeah the burly
guy what was his name
hagrid hey hug dude that sounds kind of
happy yeah
i know indian that big yo come on yeah
you're right about that i don't know
so yeah you finish the story about your
gay friend who's calling [ __ ]
yeah you just said that those are their
names
oh my god this one is texture brain
goddamn
that's my antennae
wow there were indian girls in that
[ __ ] yeah gosh connecting all the
dots bro yeah that's what we do bro
that's what that is
come on what do we got to get to the
bottom of bro the election
the election yeah we didn't figure that
out we figured out who's gonna win i
think elizabeth warren
i think elizabeth warren going she's
going to give the country back to her
ancestors
yeah indian burial ground indian barrel
ground goes right back to india you know
that's some [ __ ]
that indian barrel ground [ __ ] that [ __ ]
drives me crazy
now you know why it pissed me off bro is
because if you
claimed that your ancestors were buried
there it's just like the fake way to get
the land
you're like no no our answers are buried
there it's important to us you can have
to give it back to us
no your ancestors were buried there cuz
we
murdered
i did nothing your boy was in scotland
yeah getting smoked out by english
people yeah schmidt
we were not getting smished no y'all
were getting doggy style yeah
y'all would know
[Applause]